so the a miracle of your career is you
come out of a group like NWA which is a
hardcore [__] group right I mean with
like the baddest [__] image on the
planet was that a very sort of smart
marketing plan or it was just the
genuine thing yeah it just was genuine
you know we didn't think the group would
go further than Compton you know we
thought we was going to be neighborhoods
Stars you know get a couple extra girls
because they heard yo this rap was from
this guy as the band got bigger and
bigger and I mean the crowds got rowdier
and rowdier and police started showing
up and all that [__] were you scared for
your life sometimes on stage were you
worried that something could go horribly
wrong when when we started to get like
police to
you know threaten us before the show
right if you start talking about cops
and they said don't do that on stage
yeah you know it would be a point in the
show where everybody like all right they
wanted they you know they want us
backstage they want us backstage they
would you know round us up and uh
some [__] cop would just read the
ordinance you guys cannot do this and
then in county of Suffolk such and such
County you know this is a misdemeanor
and this is a felony and and we were
torn behind
Bobby Brown and the Beastie Boys Like
The Beastie Boys were huge change
touring forever because they was
throwing couches out Hotel windows and
[__] but they could get away with people
right yeah you know white guys they
could do it so they would trash hotels
and and act crazy so we'd come through
touring and they'd be like nah we had
the beasties you guys can't stay in this
hotel so when NWA starts having this
success and you leave yeah were you
confident that you're so your solo
career did really well yeah but were you
confident that you were going to be good
on your own or did you sort of have Dr
Dre withdrawal you like oh [__] he's my
other half of this writing team I don't
know what I'm really doing here well I
know I can rhyme you know I know I could
like do it as a solo artist but I didn't
know how we was going to produce the
music you know um right I had my man sir
Jinx with me who's Dr Dre's cousin who's
been with me the whole time sir Jinx was
in a band with you before NWA you you
say Sir Jinx taught you how to rap on
beat yeah what does that mean I'm
beating well oh I used to make acapella
wraps you know I didn't have Beats you
know so how would that go would you say
hey I'm gonna just writing a rhyme you
know I'm the best in heaven you know I'm
just right I'm right yeah yeah I'm right
I'm right what rhymes with no beat yeah
no beat right and then you know
he was he was the only one in my
neighborhood that had turntables had the
equipment and so I would go down to his
house and uh he would have Beats you
know he had records he had 12 inches so
he could put on the beat and he was like
all right rap to this and I was so off
beat that he was like nah man you gotta
kind of catch that snare and and then he
kind of put me on that Rhythm and I was
like oh okay this is what I got to do to
be on Rhythm so what a generous thing
for this guy to do like to spend time
with you he had music he had turntables
yeah and and uh and so it is a learning
curve right because when you're just
doing an acapella that you could just do
your thing yeah but when there's a beat
involved you've got a rhyme to music and
it's a whole different thing how long
before you got good at it it was it took
about two three good days of just over
and understanding the concept of it you
know where to start how to how to kind
of get into it and you know this was
when rap was no we talking about 85 84.
who what always out there doing it that
you could even emulate it was probably
uh Grandma's Flash and series five Run
DMC was just coming on with a few
singles they had just like that out and
was Public Enemy around yet not yet no
who came first you guys are Public Enemy
Public Enemy yeah we was big fans of PE
yeah NWA if you listen to that first
album we use a lot of sampling that same
samples that uh PE use can you go to Dr
Dre's house now is it still weird
between YouTube no no I can go you go
there yeah when's the last time you went
over Dre's house uh when we was uh
editing the movie I was gonna say the
movie brought you back together take me
back to the moment when you weren't
talking weren't talking things were
shitty things were shitty and then the
two of you see each other and everything
is good uh I'm awkward it was a little
awkward because he had a house in West
Lake and he was he was producing a
record called Natural Born Killers and
um you know they he just wanted me on it
he was like man this is just gonna sound
amazing and you know that's during the
death row years and he had called me and
I hadn't heard from him in forever so I
was excited to go over there and then I
go over there and he got a room full of
[__] in the house and I'm just
like where's Drake I mean the living
room is full in the backyard how is this
oh yeah
working on the beats and I go back there
and it's just him in the room is that
dangerous to have so many people in your
life when you get that successful yeah
in the background
it was intimidating right and not really
intimidating it was just like who the
where is he you just didn't know what
the scene and then when you see him what
happens do you hug and everything's fine
and it's like we never even talked about
the past we just just went forward
foreign